[Music]
just want to add my voice of a
appreciation to bill golden for all that
he's done for this field and this
subject and this position there's a
wonderful article I think you've seen it
in the New York Times today about him
and he's one of those people I into
fatigue of all it's incredible but I I'm
sure others have had the experience of
publishing something books or others and
suddenly discovering a letter in the
mail how come a copy wasn't sent to him
and how he have a sword aware I don't
never quite clear but and I suspect he
not only asked for them but reads them
all as well it's a remarkable feat in a
remarkable career I'm Eugene Skolnick
off professor of political science
emeritus now here at MIT I have the had
the wonderful experience of actually
joining the staff of the original
science office in 1958 the only person
here today I think that preceded me in
that office directly is David Becker
who's some place around who was the
first staff person in the office I
joined that office in 1958 and stayed
through most of the Kennedy
administration left in 63 and returned
later as a senior consultant to the OSTP
when Frank press was science advisor and
I spent about half time there every week
the I must say that first office at the
very beginning was something of very
unusual and great excitement because it
was quite clear that this was a really
quite seemed to be at least a new
innovation in American government there
was obviously the White House the
science operation OSRD under boniva Bush
during the war but this was the first
time this has been attempted at the in
the civilian economy and even though we
were in the midst of the Cold War and
that was the original
motivation in fact it was a very special
place to work with a with an office with
very considerable influence at the time
in part because of the weakness of the
various departments and being able to
deal with science policy issues I had
the great pleasure of working with Jim
Killian George Christie Kowski from
Harvard and Jerry Wiesner from MIT again
and the just slight personal anecdote
the I was happened before that office
was created but after Sputnik I was then
I don't know what the right term is
today but I was dating one of Robby's
daughters in New York went to pick her
up one day and was bombarded with
questions from Robby about Jim Killian
with whom I'd worked he knew I'd worked
with at MIT and I could not understand
what was going on he just kept on
pestering me with questions about what
Jim was like in person how he managed
things it said it on and on and of
course within a week discovered why when
when Killian was appointed to the new
post and then shortly after I was asked
to join him in that in that job which
set the pattern for my own personal
career and scholarship later working
particularly in the science and
international affairs area and which is
what I've been doing here at MIT since
by the way I should mention there is
another existing science advisor senior
science advisor in the US government
today science advisor to the Secretary
of State norman new writer who was
unfortunately unable to be here today
but who actually is in office he was
appointed at the end of the last
administration but on a scheduled the
appointment which is a three-year
appointment and he's still there and he
in fact is proving to be quite an
influential and a very interesting
person and Jack Gibbons had a lot to do
with his finding and selection and
appointment at the time let me go on and
and our panel today this is being done
chronologically and
two speakers are first phil smith
subbing for frank press who is the one
science advisor was unable to be here
today but phil smith was associate
director under frank press during the
Carter years and and we'll follow with
Jay Keyworth and I'll introduce them
both right now so not to have to
interrupt afterwards the Phil has long
association with science policy issues
in fact he was on the staff of the igy
in the late 1950s he worked in National
Science Foundation was director of polar
research polar programs and in 1973 was
the chief of general science research in
OMB and I think Geist Ebers already
mentioned that Phil worked with him at
the National Science Foundation as
assistant to the director in the White
House role in 1974 and then became when
the office OSTP was created became the
associate director both for guy stiver
and then stayed on with frank press
through the Carter years phil comes as
doctorate from north carolina state and
he's presently a partner in Megerian
smith and holds a whole variety of other
science related posts and activities
today jay keyworth followed after the
reagan administration started was
appointed in May 1981
so about rough roughly mid months so I
guess there's still hope that we haven't
reached the end of May and in this
administration so that he also was in
these terms a quote late appointment and
quote and he was science advisor to
President Reagan right through to
January of 1986 prior to his appointment
in the White House he was director of
the physics division of Los Alamos and
he's presently chairman of the progress
and Freedom Foundation and of the firm
that he started the Keyworth company
which consultants to industry
particularly on innovation and
strategist strategic planning to cope
with new
jeez and emerging technologies dr.
Keyworth comes from Boston glad to say
but not from MIT studied at Yale and as
a PhD from Duke let's start off with
Bill Thank You Jean and Thank You
president vest and professor Hastings
for organizing this conference let me
start by expressing Frank press's deep
personal regret that he could not be
here today he extends his best wishes to
all of his fellow science advisors and
all of you I thought that I would divide
my remarks into two parts today the
first part will be mostly focused on the
operating environment for OSTP during
the Carter presidency and the second
part will be focused briefly on some of
the work that we did in the major issues
that we worked on in the late 1970s I
did do a longer written paper that maybe
in a colloquium volume that discusses
some of the interplay between the
offices in the executive office the
White House staff and work with the
Congress and with the cabinet you'll
find for example a note that I have in
that paper that describes the Cabinet
Room budget session we had with the
president and the energy secretary and
the energy secretary didn't like our
analysis and he tried to dismiss it by
saying mr. president those arguments are
the fuzzy-headed thinking and analytical
analyses of the MIT professors and in
that instance at least the president
cited with his science advisor well as
we're discovering and we will continue
to discover as we go through this
morning session east each presidency is
a kind of a remarkable collage a complex
painting that starts with the camp
the voters decisions the very early
decisions that a president has to make
that start immediately to in dealing
with the unexpected and anticipated
activities that forced their way into
the presidency and it's in this
environment that each science advisor
has to kind of find his way or hopefully
someday her way into the operating
environment and learn how to be an
effective player in a White House staff
now our transition from Ford Carter was
really the first test of the OSTP Act
and it was the first transition after
the legislation was passed we had a lot
of good things going for us one of them
was that we were a Frank was appointed
very early identified and actually
appointed and confirmed and so as a
consequence the whole participation in
the machinery of the White House the
daily meeting in the Roosevelt Room in
the morning meetings with the leaders of
the other executive office groups like
CEA the economic advisors OMB and so
forth that all began to flow very early
President Carter had a personal interest
in science and technology as well as a
deep understanding of the fact that
science and technology is needed in a
lot of decision-making so he would turn
to us on technical and scientific
questions but he also would turn
occasionally to us to ask a question
that had to do more of this personal
curiosity about science and engineering
and he would really say he would stop a
cabinet meeting for example to get into
some issue of basic research with Frank
that caused all the other advisors to
wonder what in the world was going on at
that moment now in addition to the fact
that we had early appointments another
important thing that was a valuable was
the access
a lot of the press and the science
community only thinks about the access
to the presidency and in the old days
there used to be a kind of a measurement
of how many times the science advisor
saw the president access is very
important and Frank had good access
along with the other senior advisors and
we got very fast turnaround on memos to
the president sometimes overnight but
equally important is the way in which
the science adviser and his staff is
able to begin to work with the other
offices in the White House and bring
technology and science advice together
with the other kinds of advice that
economic advice the financial and
budgetary advice that all has to be put
together in what ultimately becomes a
presidential decision and so the early
setup and the early operation helped us
a great deal on that front another thing
that was very important was that by the
early appointment Frank was able to
participate in the selection of the R&D
agency heads for most of the other Rd
agency leaders of the Carter presidency
and that was a very important now
President Carter decided that he did not
want to have a Science and Technology
Committee there was this committee that
been put in place for the two-year
period
to study the idea of the future of the
organization of science in the
government and the feasibility of a
permanent committee but President Carter
felt that there had been a proliferation
of presidential committee standing
committees and he wanted to trim down
the total number so as a consequence we
discharged the committee that just a
matter of a year before I had helped set
up in the Ford presidency and we
operated with ad-hoc committees many
appointed by the President himself of
many panels we convened ourselves and we
also used the National Academy of
Sciences on several quick turnaround
studies now the science community and
many of the congressmen
who had been involved in the setting up
of the OSTP legislation where of course
angry about the fact that we weren't
going to have a committee but the
reality is that if the president does
not want to use a piece of the OSTP
legislation it's counterproductive to
try to use it so we did not try to do
that there are on all presidencies
unexpected events some of which have
science and technology components in our
period we dealt with Mount st. Helens
the volcanic eruption with the Three
Mile Island nuclear power plant accident
and with a mysterious light flash over
the South Pacific that a satellite had
picked up that could have been a nuclear
explosion by a testing nation and those
issues and many other issues the
president turned immediately to the OSTP
and to Frank and asked us to be the lead
on on working on those issues
our staff number 232 only we had a
science advisor three associate
directors Ben Huberman who handled
national security and had a dual
appointment with NSC staff yellow man
who's now a vice president at the
University of Michigan for health who
handled health and biomedical research
and I handled natural resources energy
basic research and university industry
relations the four of us had white house
mess privileges and for those of you who
have not been there you cannot
appreciate the importance of the mess as
an instrument of policy making it is
very important now our we had some
problems with the Carter presidency and
as long ago enough now that it can be
talked about perhaps a little more
analytically than Jack or or Neil would
be able to talk about the Clinton
presidency we had much strength that we
had some weaknesses the first weakness
was as is in many presidencies we had a
number of people who were fiercely loyal
to the president who had been in the
campaign they were more loyal to the
president than they were interested in
governance and they came in often many
of them were young they had come out of
small state government some of them
actually were in the first jobs they
ever had they had been campaign workers
and came to a job in the White House and
that was their first job some were
ill-equipped for example the first
director of White House personnel knew
nothing about the structure of the
government what the mission of the
agencies were so this required a good
deal of patience intact to kind of
nurture and tutor these people somewhat
reminiscent actually of something Jack
faced in the early part of the Clinton
administration I remember going to a
meeting with Jack and the EOB about six
months in and our combined ages were
equal to the eight other people in the
room the enduring weakness however was a
serious weakness and it affected us on
many things we were working on from
setting up an International Institute
that I mentioned in a minute to getting
a structure in place the handle
radioactive waste which is still a
problem and that was that even though
both houses of Congress were under
Democratic control President Carter and
the Congress did not get along well with
each other
and so and this lasted over the whole
four years of the presidency and so when
we would go up to the hill to talk to
committees and staff we would frequently
find ourselves being pink cushions for
the first five or ten minutes while a
people on the hill we're taking out
their anger on the White House
legislative staff on us so you would sit
there calmly and absorb that and then
you would get on with your business
now that unfortunately endured over the
whole time you have to understand that
it in part it was also a tension and a
relationship that carried over from the
Watergate period and the Nixon
impoundment battle
that he had with the Congress over the
budget over a period of a couple of
three years so there was a great deal of
hostility toward the imperial presidency
that had been built up and then when you
had a president whose congressional
relations were not as smooth as they
should have been it just sort of
exacerbated the whole thing there were
four big themes as I look back now on
what we did 25 years ago and I'll
mention one or two points about some of
our successes and failures the first
issue was that we focused the good deal
of energy on increasing funding for
basic research not only for NIH and NSF
but for all the mission agencies of the
government the two forward budgets had
turned around the decline that had begun
in 1968 so we continued the build-up of
basic research in the mission agencies
we continued a program a guy had started
an agriculture for competitive grant
program and were frustrated there as
were many of our successors because
Congress was not enthusiastic about that
program we had great success in work we
did with the Defense Department bill
Perry was the defense director of
defense research and engineering and we
started a lot of basic research
activities for example in material
science that directly led to the kind of
stealth technologies that saw their
deployment in the Gulf War there were
concerns about the decline in American
industrial innovation this was right
after the Bicentennial and our we had
Percy we were perceiving that Japan and
the European countries and companies
were rising we organized an NFC like
review that involved all the cabinet of
officers of the government to review
government policies on innovation and
out of that flowed a whole large list of
administrative changes for example a
number of changes in the Patent Office
a change in the ERISA act that allowed
pension funds to be invested in venture
capital clarification of antitrust
policy so that pre competitive research
could be undertaken some of these
matters required continued support in
the Reagan presidency and I'm happy to
say that Bruce Merrifield Jordan Bruce's
successor he was the point man on this
in commerce for us he carried on
Muirfield carried on and let and there
were things passed then in 81 and 82
such as the bayh-dole act that now we
look back on as ancient history we
worked a great deal on the regulatory
front and also on energy science and
technology by the late 70s we had been
10 years into the regulatory and
environmental regimes that had fallen
into place in the late 1960s and it was
beginning to be apparent that the
science base needed a checkout and an
improvement there were local areas where
we were really just simply baking making
regulations on the basis of inadequate
understanding of science so we put a lot
of work in on that had some cross agency
teams that looked at a framework for
assessing carcinogen risk we spent a lot
of time as I mentioned on nuclear waste
a lot of time on diesel emissions
because that was a point when diesel
emissions were coming into the fleet a
third area with a lot in which we put a
lot of emphasis was on international
matters President Carter was interested
in building up the capacity of
developing nations in there in science
and technology
our biggest paydirt success maybe of the
Carter presidency was the mission Frank
led to China of government leaders to
set up the formal agreements that were
signed by Deng Xiaoping and the
president in 1979 when Frank was in
China he cautioned the vice premier that
some of the students that studied in the
United States would probably want to
stay here without missing a beat the
vice premier said dr. press we have
plenty more the fourth area that we
worked on we had one big defeat I should
mention in the international area and
that was this organization that we were
jeans calling off work very hard on as
did others to set up something called
the Institute for scientific and
technical cooperation and it was to be
an agency that would build
infrastructure in developing countries
in science the Senate appropriation
committee did not like the idea and so
it did not come to pass
we did get some part of it built into
aide later on but that I can tell you
about a coffee break if we want to let
me make an observation or two in
conclusion one is that we benefited a
lot in our time because of the work that
had gone on with the pre or the prior
science advisors and with people like
Bill Baker sy Remo saw Buxbaum so there
was a kind of a transitional and it's
typical of science and engineering in
policy there is a kind of a
bipartisanship to be sure there's some
partisanship but by and large there's a
kind of a continuity several speakers
have mentioned that it carried on into
the Reagan presidency art Biko was in
the Reagan transition team and I had
known him when he was an officer in the
Industrial Research Institute so I
worked a great deal over the first
months of the Reagan presidency with him
as I was exiting OSTP on passing forward
the mantle so to speak the second
interesting thing and this is a
particularly this was it was very
provocative comments by IDI point this
up the issues we worked on in that
period of time in many instances are the
same issues that are important now at
the beginning of the 21st century and
somehow we still have this Mis mismatch
between in our government between the
longer horizons of scientists and
scientists and engineers and the
solutions required
and the short horizons of the political
process
that makes for this rocky and erratic
course that we go forward on on anything
like energy technology where a slow
steady sustaining course would probably
be the course thank you very much we're
running a little slow but I think we
have time for one or two brief questions
if there are any yes right here
yes asking about nuclear waste that a
lot of the issues you dealt with then
are still very much in the in the for
today what do you think a more permanent
solution looks like for the United
States as we deal with us I'll tell you
nutshell what happened I didn't know
that the timer was able to ask questions
but I'll be brief and answering the
timer the framework that we put in place
that ultimately was enacted in 81 and 82
for high and low level waste was a very
good framework it had all the right
technical parameters for example going
forward with the exploration of a number
of geologic media not just one
confidence building with the state and
local governments so that you began to
get more confidence in the fact that the
process would in effect lead to a public
publicly arrived at decision that
included the public what happened was
that as often as the case succeeding
directors of energy secretaries of
energy utility companies they all get
anxious to go forward quickly so we
immediately went back to the idea by
Fiat of declaring to waste sites the
plant in New Mexico and the Nevada site
so there was no comparative geologic
investigation the
two states felt that they had been
singled out to be the dumping grounds so
the process immediately broke down it
then got going again and variously but
meanwhile the public attitudes changed
and there was an increasing resistance
to nuclear power so that remains today
an issue that we are a long way from
getting worked out and we ironically at
this moment there's a prospect of
nuclear power getting a restart for a
whole lot of reasons but we do not have
the waste problem solved and that's a
big issue
[Applause]
well it's it's good of MIT and of the
sloan foundation both to sponsor this
symposium because clearly it is a timely
topic now the issue of just how just how
science advice can be most effective to
the white house remains a challenging
one probably not much less so than when
the Congress first created OSTP 25 years
ago
OST Rio STP remains somewhat of an
anomaly among executive offices viewed
by some White House staffers as an asset
but by some others as an imposition how
a consensus among these diverging views
emerges assuming it does will have much
to do with how the office will be able
to function and circumstances differ
each of us has advised different
presidents at least at different times
priorities varied pressures were
different and personalities created very
different relationships in my comments
today I'm going to dwell somewhat
primarily in fact on some of the actual
relationships that develop during my
tenure because they in fact were
essential to how I was able to be
effective
now I joined the Reagan administration
just about now
in early May four months after the
inauguration and shortly after the
assassination attempt during the first
few months as well as during the
transition planning there had been a lot
of debate over whether a science adviser
was in fact needed the opposition
stemmed largely from the perception that
OSTP was created to represent the
scientific community while White House
staff was there in fact to serve the
president in other words a number of the
president's closest and trusted friends
and advisors viewed a science adviser
and somehow likely to be different from
them and likely to come with an agenda
that might differ from the president's
the countervailing view which eventually
prevailed was simply that since so many
of the administration's top
Dirty's for example defense energy in
their cut and the economy were deeply
rooted in science and technology they
would need a team member with competency
in science without expertise on the
president's policy team the White House
would be dependent upon the external
agencies by the time I was invited to
Washington as a candidate for science
advisor the debate was over and resolved
and I really felt welcome now in its
first term the process of policy
development in the Reagan administration
was conducted in a somewhat more
centrally organized manner than in some
administrations if not most edwin meese
bearing the title of counselor to the
president coordinated all policy-making
whether domestic defense or foreign this
wide-ranging power along with Ed's real
talent for the job and his uniquely
close personal relationship with the
president led to him being referred to
as deputy president one of the means
that used a coordinate policy
development was to hold meetings each
evening in his office with leaders of
each White House office involved in
policy matters including OMB the crucial
one to discuss both tactical issues as
well as strategic areas of opportunity
as a member ed Meese made it possible
for me to early on develop a
relationship with the President as I
will explain and with the president's
senior staff now a president has in fact
many assistants but few bona fides
advisers and only he makes a distinction
my relationship with Ronald Reagan began
with his light reference to me as his
personal Merlin
ed meese was to play a major role in how
I and OSTP were to move beyond that
simple perception in the summer of 1981
one of the Reagan children began to
appear frequently in the press and
apparent sympathy with a number of
anti-nuclear activists worrying about
her being exploited the president turned
to ed Meese for advice and suggested
that I might help the president then
called me to ask if I'd mind coming over
to talk about a personal matter I did
sensing that she would probably not
react well to his own counsel the
president simply asked me if I would go
out to California and talk with her and
I did and that became the first step in
developing a relationship with the
president now just a few weeks later the
president called unexpectedly also I'm
sure it at Mesa suggestion on a Saturday
morning Mastiffs I'd mind coming over to
discuss an issue that he was pondering
he put the question quite simply a lot
of good people were suggesting to him
that we commit a hundred billion dollars
or lots more to this new technology
called stealth and he needed to know
some basics before going along with that
in particular he asked me does it work
and if so will it continue to do so now
this was a turning point for me because
I started to give an answer but I
suddenly realized that this wasn't
exactly the kind of scientific dialogue
I was used to at Los Alamos you see here
there would be no opportunity to revise
my first estimate fortunately I deferred
an answer until I could be more
confident as it turned out it took
several months in fact it took several
man years as a result of that simple
question as to the viability of stealth
and the challenge that responding to and
entailed we were able to develop within
OSTP some substantial expertise in some
of the more arcane and more sensitively
classified areas of defense technology
in stealth and anti-submarine warfare
and space-based surveillance
and other key technologies that underlay
our defense modernization efforts we
became credentialed and I think a valued
component of the president's team we had
been assigned a role in defense the
administration's top priority and as a
result I became a regular attendee of
the national security planning group the
pared down version of the cabinet that
dealt with issues of national security
and one point worth noting here in
passing is that some of the inherent
constraints faced by osp's external
advisory process previously known as the
Peace Action now PCAST and what we
called the White House Science Council
or the whisk now since it was
unthinkable to obtain clearances for
each of the whisk members too many of
the really sensitive areas that we were
involved in it became a real challenge
for me to find a way to carry on a much
needed dialogue with my respected
advisors but to do so within at least
some reasonable respect for the rules
perhaps at David or Allan Bromley may
recall my discussing with whisk in 1983
the idea that we just might have
operational aircraft with certain
hypothetical radar evading capabilities
that this was a chronic problem now
returning to a specific in the fall of
1982 finding a politically acceptable
basing mode for the land-based
MX missile had become a critical problem
for the administration as the final link
in the administration's strategic
modernization program much Hendon's
hinged on solving this one lingering
problem many options were reviewed a
process in which OSTP played a prominent
role which finally agreement began to
emerge focusing on a highly arcane
concept called dense pack
however a debate arose over just who
would articulate the technically complex
rationale behind the decision to the
Congress and to the public
in an effort to resolve an impasse
between NSC and the Pentagon OSTP was
asked to take on the task and it took
months of effort by a good portion of
the OSTP staff and turned out to be a
task where to put it lightly success was
elusive but with battle scars and all we
did acquire some more legitimacy and
essentially we had begun to acquire some
chips about this time I began to learn
some basics about how Washington really
works
fortunately early in my tenure in
Washington an acquaintance had suggested
that I refreshed myself in the pervasive
wisdom to be found in Machiavelli's
writings especially in the prints
perhaps the greatest treatise ever
written on the exploitation of power
unlike business you see Washington is
much more about power than it is about
process where we and OSTP most needed
power was in the budget process and
specifically in negotiation with OMB
while the administration had agreed that
funding for basic research particularly
in universities deserve the protection
that van neva Bush wishes term of a
federal trust first defined there was of
course a range of opinion as to just
what funding increases were needed
now the 70s had been a generally tough
decade for basic research especially
with a high rates of inflation of the
previous few years and we and OSTP felt
that some pretty heroic funding
increases were required and this is
where we chose to cash in our chips the
annual increases in NSF's budget of near
20% the introduction of a number of new
programs such as the NSF Centers and
Young Investigator Awards new facilities
not in agencies budgets were each the
results of negotiations where such chips
were required
now while each of these thrusts did
represent administration policy the end
of
initiatives were in fact obtained only
because OMB knew that we were willing to
let ed meese or even the president
resolve differences of how to implement
those policies finally let me come to
the single issue that most shaped OSTP
in the Reagan years certainly the one
that had the most impact and which
remains to this day the most
controversial from my very earliest days
with the president he often spoke to me
about his concerns over the basic
premises upon which nuclear deterrence
is founded after being briefed on the
prospect of depressed trajectory
missiles launched from Soviet submarines
off our Atlantic coast reducing warning
times to less than three minutes he
asked and I will never forget this and
I'm expected to make the most awesome
decision anyone has ever made that fast
and on the basis of what you call bits
most of all he understood the importance
of measuring deterrence by the concept
of stability the all-important condition
that defines the likelihood of
preemption as did his predecessors he
came to understand the large the
fundamental but largely unspoken
implications for stability in the
transition from countervalue deterrence
where population centers were targeted
and counter force deterrence where the
target is the opponent's retaliatory
capability silos he came to understand
what many arms control advocates has
chosen to overlook and that was the
erosion of stability that this entailed
during his first two years strategic
force modernization and rebuilding the
military was the president's top
priority and he was immersed in every
aspect of this issue himself in weighing
the various options for modernizing our
strategic forces in moving arms control
from the salt framework to start and
simply in trying to understand the
Soviet Union's motives and intentions
President Reagan grappled with all the
intricacies of managing deterrence
as a consequence of all is he decided to
embark upon a path that became SDI or
his Strategic Defense Initiative
expressed most simply he concluded that
the stability of deterrence was eroding
that it was wrong and that there had to
be a better way in the long term to
ensure our national security and it
never occurred to him that such a thing
as a perfect defence did or ever would
exist what he did believe is that any
incentive for a pre-emptive nuclear
attack could be removed by even a
rudimentary missile defense system that
the ABM Treaty was rooted in pre counter
force deterrence and the Soviet doctrine
would be threatened by such a strategic
shift by the United States and assuredly
it was the SDI was President Reagan's
idea it was his initiative and it was
his faith in technology that drove it my
role was as a trusted adviser and to
tell him what was possible much has been
written about the fact that the
president's SDI speech was conceived in
less than a week in fact the president
began to articulate the rationale behind
the speech in late 1981 18 months
earlier the president wrote virtually
the entire speech himself I did advise
him I did help him edit the speech and I
offered him choices throughout it for
restating key points I did my best to
explain the president's intent to other
members of his staff and his cabinet
George Shultz in his book turmoil and
triumph argues that the president relied
far too heavily on my advice I don't
think so one need only re-examine how
Ronald Reagan carried out his
negotiations personally with Mikhail
Gorbachev to see just how independent
and determined the president could be he
had from the beginning a clear vision of
where he was leading the country and SDI
was part of how to get there I believe
that he was right that he was courageous
and undertaking SDI and it was certainly
my privilege to serve him in that
endeavor but he and he alone made the
estimates of the risks and benefits and
he never wavered from that point on
though I
did become no question a single-issue
science advisor those were my orders the
president asked me to be his spokesman
on SDI and in particular while the
diplomatic processes were trying to
position SDI as a pawn in arms control I
was traveling the world carrying the
president's message that SDI was never
and would never be open for negotiation
only much later at Reykjavik was his
commitment to SDI established beyond
doubt
now as you think of how things should be
with science advice I suspect that these
experiences are not quite irrelevant
thank you Thanks thank you very much Jay
any questions Granger Morgan
the arc is that the pendulum in play a
role in fact the occurred exactly the
same time was the the whole nuclear
freeze movement which the president had
lots and lots of folks he in fact he
asked us to bring in him lots of lots of
folks who had been spokesman in that
movement because the cross-section of
concerned parties was a lot broader than
in most anti-nuclear movements so and
there were a lot of very very very
rational people but let me make a point
the the president arrived at SDI from
really one reason that would because of
trying to find a way to manage the
intricacies of modernizing strategic
forces to achieve a higher level of
stability time after time the president
made comparisons to me between the
decisions that JFK had to make with
Minuteman when he could with with
certainty look forward to 20 years of a
very stable condition remember stability
is defined as a condition in which
preemption is inconceivable and no
matter what we were doing it was
becoming increasingly an action reaction
offense/defense challenge much more
complicated and that is really the
reason why we did SDI and Hedrick Smith
does not say that it was a bit I beg to
differ
go back and read it more carefully he
discusses it much more carefully than
than that the Catholic Bishops move was
a fair and I agree it was effective I
would not place it amongst the top 15 or
20 factors I would say that if you go
back and look for example to go back and
look at a visit that the president took
before he was president to I think in
1978 or 1979 to the command and control
system in Colorado
and beginning to really discover the
window that one has to make a
retaliatory decision if you really want
to go back to the first factor it
affected him I think that's where it
came from
I'm afraid this is a soft topic which we
could go on for a very long time Jay
thank you very much change roles
open mic room was actually for the
counseling competiveness meeting that
was here in March of 1998 and I had just
been recently confirmed in my position
and that meeting was very profound for
me because the council met to decide
what was going to make or continue to
make American corporations more
competitive in the next 10 years and
what we're going to be the things are
going to limit the growth of the
American corporation in America and what
came out of that meeting was workforce
that was a big issue it had to do with
k-12 education the and so I got very
much interested in that whole issue as a
matter of international competitiveness
and I just want to share with you a
couple of view graphs that have come out
of that that I think are kind of
important one of the things that came
out and we've all heard about may have
heard about is over the next decade
we're going to need three million oh
sorry there will have any about 2.2 new
k-12 teachers we have a total workforce
of 3 million k12 teachers so if you
think it's going to be easy to recruit
science and math teachers in the next
decade
you're kidding itself it's going to be a
very very difficult task and we really
need to address that the other part is
where people are going and what people
are choosing from majors and I have one
view graph that some of you have seen
but it's one of my favorites because it
shows the history of majors Electrical
Engineering from 1986 to 1998 and the
1999 number is continues along that
linear path and you see it isn't one of
those things it has ups and downs it's
just a straight line to zero and if the
current rate will be at zero sometime in
the year 2010 that's a problem but there
is a major that of course Chuck knows
all about which is my favorite major in
the whole world which is buried behind
here and then goes up here and now
exceeds the number of electrical
engineering majors and that major is
parks recreation and leisure fitness
studies
now as I've told other college
presidents and dr. Shapiro would want to
do this also clearly electrical
engineering is not a growth industry for
you growth industry is this new major
and you better get on the bandwagon very
quickly but it points out something
about our society we think of the 1990s
as being a highly technological society
and our growth on economic growth being
based on technology and yet that's not
where students are going they're going
in other fields and this is true of
other physics based engineering fields
they only feel this can has actually
seen an upturn and so the numbers for
total engineering enrollments actually
have turned around is because of
biomedical engineering BMA is solely the
one that's going up not the physics
based engineering fields and that is a
real problem now I want to compare that
I'm gonna give two graphs of
international issues the United States
graduates more baccalaureate students
that anybody else in the world although
of our million students and I've given
you the top ten countries in the world
and the reason I got interested in this
was actually the number under China you
notice that China Wave in the right-hand
column that normalized the number of 24
year olds and what you see is only 1.4
percent of 24 year olds in China
receive baccalaureate degrees and I was
thinking of what does that mean for a
country over the next 20 to 40 years it
has profound impacts on that and so
you'd say oh gee China's not gonna be
very competitive but let me show you one
more view graph quickly and let's order
them by who grants the most engineering
degrees this does not include physics
chemistry and the other physical
sciences because the way the data is
structured it's hard to pull that out so
if you include the physics and chemistry
majors in China you're going to get a
number of this more like 60% now you
have to understand in China you're
probably not going to major in political
science you're probably not going to
major in social science and of course
like other countries like former Soviet
Union science and engineering was an a
political major that you go into but
this has a very profound impact because
notice the United States here is
graduating about 40 percent of the same
number of majors in engineering right
now as Chinese and so as a matter of
public policy this is
very interesting effect and then finally
my other view graph and if anybody wants
these view graphs afterwards just give
me a business card that says with the
word data on it and I'll email them to
you there's only two numbers I want you
to look at the one are PhDs which is
45,000 the number of lawyers there is
almost one lawyer
for every PhD being graduated in this
country so if you believe this is going
to become a less litigious society over
the next decade they want to be employed
two engineers 6,200 and his Chuck is
mentioned about 30,000 of those in that
year were foreign students and then
finally that other number I want you to
show is we think of this being
information technology era look at the
number of PhDs in computer science that
is not a typo it's 857 the good news is
it's down 1% it's only down 1% and
that's only 8 people but the problem is
we have a critical workforce situation
that's coming up over the next decade so
now it's my pleasure to introduce the
three advisors from the period of
1998-2005 on who was the advisor under
Bush from 1989 to 93 Ellen of course is
very very well known in the physics
community he received the National Medal
of Science in 1988 he's a member of the
National Academy of Science he's been
president of triple a s in the American
Physical Society he's won the Benjamin
Franklin fellow of the Royal Society of
Arts in London he's a founding partner
of the Washington Weiser II group and of
course the most important thing is he is
a PhD from the University of Rochester
my home institution on a personal note
ellen was one of the people I went to
when we were both serving on the AIP
board when I was thinking about coming
to Washington and going to work for Jack
and he really encouraged me to do that
and I really appreciate that
recommendation the second speaker is
Jack Gibbons who was the first science
advisor under President Clinton from
1993 to 98 previously that he'd been at
OTA for 13 years
he's currently president of Sigma's I
he's a member of the National Academy of
Engineering and his PhD is from some
small school down south called Duke
something that's not in his write up
that I think is important that he raises
horses he is a wonderful farm out in
Plains Virginia and he's been very very
nice to people in hosting the OSTP
family out there on his facility there
but ah that's you know I didn't and you
know it doesn't oh yeah it does say your
PhDs in physics doesn't say parks
recreation on a personal note though he
is the guy that hired me at OSTP back in
1997 and that had a very profound effect
on me it really helped me and I grew in
a very different direction I really
thank Jack for that but finally not but
not last but not least is me Elaine who
succeeded Jack is science advisor in
1998 and served till 2000 oh yeah
the most recent good point this is a
tough audience here previous to that
he'd been the director of the National
Science Foundation previous of that he
was the provost at Rice University he is
now the only University professor at
Rice now nioi
since I worked with him for a long time
we have lots of good stories about Neil
but I don't tell a couple I set Neil up
three different times well he was
director and each time I promised it
would never happen again and each time I
went something like the following meal
somebody and it was either the sequence
was Attorney General Reno secretary
Leila and the third one was sandy Berger
and each time I said to him okay you
start your speech and they will be here
when your speech finishes and the last
words are you for you to introduce them
so he starts a speech with the person up
in the audience and every time they
weren't there and he had to go into a
song-and-dance routine
to fill up the material and each time I
apologize I wouldn't have it again and I
guess it can't happen again now Neil was
a wonderful person so Ellen
[Applause]
Duncan and it is a great pleasure to
have this opportunity to see so many old
friends and colleagues and I would on
all of our behalf
add my thanks to Chuck vest and Dan
Hastings for putting together this
celebration of the 25th anniversary of
the OSTP founding now in the brief time
that's available this morning instead of
trying to give you a laundry list of
what went on during the Bush
administration I'm going to focus on
three areas into which I think we
achieved reasonable success and one
where I think we could have been much
more successful if we had managed things
a little better one of my first tasks in
the office was to respond to requests
from the president for five or six items
in science and technology areas in
science and technology that fulfill
three conditions first of all they were
of national importance
secondly they involved a significant
fraction of the 20-some agencies that
maintained research programs in
furtherance of their own missions and
third that they were of sufficient
importance that they merited the
attention of a president and so in order
to select these one of the real
requirements was that we revitalize the
federal Coordinating Council for science
engineering and technology a group that
had this somewhat unfortunate acronym of
fix it and having pulled this group
together we selected the following areas
as being of importance enough to meet
these criteria
the first was mathematics and science
education for the simple reason that
unless we were going to do something to
improve our K through 12 education
everything else that he had hoped to do
was clearly going to be doomed this has
been mentioned many times it will be
mentioned many times by other people
now the second item was advanced
computation and communication that
because we felt that the nation was not
taking adequate advantage of the
information revolution and we
established a group of Grand Challenges
which I must say we thought it would
take four or five years to even begin to
accomplish it took something like six to
eight months
the third was global climate change and
the reason there was because that was a
topic that had boiled to the top of the
political agenda in countries around the
world and we in the US had interests
both internal and external material
science and synthesis because in almost
all cases the efficiency of industrial
processes are limited ultimately by the
behavior of materials some materials
usually at high temperature then
biotechnology because biotechnology is
uniquely an American technology
reflecting the fruits of 40 years of
generous funding of fundamental biology
in the nation's universities the
research universities and a field that
holds high promise not only in health
where it's been focused thus far but
also in agriculture and eventually in
manufacturing then advanced
manufacturing because we believe that we
were in the process of losing a lead
which this nation had held since its
founding and
we're losing it rather rapidly finally
it was International Science and
Technology and their because although we
still had and now have the strongest
Science and Technology Enterprise that
the world has ever seen the fact is that
by focusing their activities other
nations have been able to move up in
particular areas to Equalists and in
some to surpasses and this is not
surprising but what it meant was that it
was very important for us to be informed
and to have decent communications and
cooperation with these other nations now
in each of these areas under the ficks
gardens we pull together representatives
from all the involved agencies they
elected their own chairman in each case
and in following several months first of
all they made an inventory of what the
government was doing in all of these
areas and in every case we were
astonished to find that the government
was doing vastly more than anyone had
previously recognized secondly they
produced a budget for the coming year
and in last detail a budget for each of
the five out years this took an enormous
amount of work it involved something
over 2,000 federal scientists and
technologists a rather amazing
transformation took place during this
process in the beginning everyone was
very wary and there was a lot of secrecy
and agency representatives kept their
papers very close to their chests but
after a few months we found that in fact
we were getting much more communication
much more cooperation and much more
trust
beyond that each of the representatives
was extremely loath to see their agency
appear in a bad light among its peers
and they were very much taken by the
fact that they as individuals were
participating in developing programs for
the nation in areas of major importance
now once these committees had agreed on
the various roles that various agencies
would play in these presidential
initiatives as they came to be called
OMB working with OSTP froze all the
funds and that was simply because we
didn't want agency people to request
funding for the presidential initiatives
and then moved them somewhere else it's
not that we didn't trust them we just
understood a perfectly human reaction
now whatever wasn't very key point
whenever the recommendations of a fix-it
committee disagreed with the
recommendations of an agency head or a
department secretary there was no
question the agency had and the
department secretary had the last word
and because we emphasized that from the
very start the question never arose
during our four years now each year each
of these committees produced a booklet
it well illustrated that was an appendix
to the president's submission budget
submission to the Congress and we found
out after the fact that these booklets
had been translated into at least 10
languages because the parent governments
had decided that these were models for
how a federal government should develop
programs
for Science and Technology in effect
then the Bush administration had a
two-tier budget structured program first
of all there were a limited number some
five or six programs that were
presidential initiatives where the
agency participation was very highly
coordinated for the rest of the agency's
portfolio it was as always built from
the bottom up on the basis of proposals
submitted from across the nation because
these special programs were recognized
as presidential initiatives each year we
were able to convince the Congress to
provide appropriation increases between
twenty and forty percent and in
consequence of course we were able to
move these fields forward in rather
striking fashion and I feel that this
activity and this two-tier budget
structure was a reasonable success next
item I want to turn to is that of
Technology from the outset from the very
first when I arranged to have one of our
associate directors appointed for
Industrial Technology I was trying to
send out two messages first of all that
the Bush administration wished to
cooperate with the private sector in the
development of generic or enabling
technologies and secondly that the Bush
administration was interested in
improving the rather unhappy
relationships that sometimes exist
between the federal government and the
private sector as one of our first tax
we undertook to try and find out exactly
what the US technology policy was and so
in November of 1990 we published the
first ever statement of US technology
policy
it's interesting to note that it took us
about a month to prepare that statement
and nine months to get it through the
legal thicket before it could be signed
off by the President and published
obviously it involves technology but
perhaps even more important it involved
the other components that are important
in the technology policy that involve
taxation regulation the availability of
capital the availability of an
adequately skilled workforce appropriate
intellectual property protection and
communication channels with other
nations and I must say here that I just
wanted to pay tribute again to Bill
golden with whose help we put together
the carnegie group this was and is an
excellent group because it enabled us
over the years to convert international
issues by back-channel telephone
conversations before they became
international problems and that is still
going on now you will remember well that
our administration was the one where the
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisers Michael Baskin was widely
quoted in the national media as having
said quote $100 worth of potato chips
$100 worth of computer chips what's the
difference and who cares Michael of
course swears that he never made any
such statement but the very fact that
this quotation was widely distributed
widely read in the private sector
suggested to many there that that might
actually be the administration's point
of view and so we had to come up with
some programs that would address this we
recognized that the public was becoming
increasingly dissatisfied with the
return
it's 25 billion dollar-a-year roughly 25
billion dollar-a-year investment in the
National Laboratories and we undertook a
major program to bring them together
with the private sector and in
particular with small and mid-sized
industries in that sector by the end of
the Bush administration as a matter of
fact we had more than 2,500 of the
so-called craters cooperative research
and development agreements signed and in
place and in the middle of the Bush
administration
we started what we at the time viewed as
a pilot program the advanced technology
program that we based in NIST because we
recognized that NIST had a long history
of cooperation and interaction with the
private sector and the idea was a very
simple one namely to develop cooperation
between the federal government and the
small and mid-sized companies and
corporations that did not have adequate
resources to do the research that would
make them competitive on an
international marketplace the results of
the first year were encouraging and so
in the second year we convinced the
Congress to give us substantially
increased appropriations and throughout
the election campaign in 1992 both Bill
Clinton and Al Gore repeatedly noted
that they liked the program and that
they were going to increase its
appropriations and this they did but
unfortunately with the increase in
appropriations came a change in the
character of the program and the
emphasis moved from the small and
mid-sized companies to some very large
companies as for example the three major
automobile manufacturers in the program
for a new generation of vehicles and
perhaps not surprisingly this convinced
members of Congress to label this
program as corporate welfare on the
assumption of such corporations these
large corporations should have been
expected to do the necessary research
using their own resources and because of
this corporate welfare label which I
think was unfair and only slightly
reasonable the funding for the advanced
technology program dropped significantly
in the latter Clinton years and
unhappily in the george w budget which
has just recently been released funding
for ATP has been terminated completely
and i happen to believe that in its
initial form this was a very important
program and one that would still have
major benefits for the nation and is
worth considering again lastly let me
turn to the President's Council of
Advisors on science and technology that
council was the first in something like
30 years that reported directly to the
president it was part of a promise that
George HW had made in October prior to
the election where he said that he is
going to do two things he was going to
raise the science advisor position to
that of assistant to the president and
he was going to appoint a counsel of
private citizens that would report
directly to him and advise him now as I
mentioned earlier it took us nine months
to get the technology policy out but we
had noted that Eisenhower nine days
after he formed P sack had held its
first meeting and so we figured well it
can't take that long but it did it took
in fact nine months between the time we
started and we were able to get all
all of our member is cleared and in
place so that we could hold our first
meeting of the Bush PCAST at Camp David
as the guest of George and Barbara Bush
now the fact that the president met
regularly with PCAST in its monthly
meetings I can't see it rolling to get
the idea
roughly meant with the group PCAST group
whenever he was in Washington when it
met for its monthly meetings made an
enormous difference because the members
recognized that they were having input
to the very highest levels of the
nation's government when the members had
first been appointed we had asked them
to be prepared to devote one week per
month to PCAST activity unfortunately as
time passed I and the other members of
my OSTP staff who were supposed to be
working with the president in developing
tasks that we would ask PCAST to do
found that we simply had so many
competing activities that over time we
let this part of our agenda slip away
and although the Bush PCAST
first of all who is comprised of
extraordinarily distinguished private
citizens it produced a whole series of
really important studies it generated a
whole series of reports to the president
which are still extremely useful it
didn't and wasn't asked to do anything
like one week per month of activity on
behalf of the President and in that
sense I feel
that in fact we wasted one of the very
major resources that was available to
our administration and before I leave it
though let me emphasize just how
important I think it is to have a group
of private citizens like this that would
interact directly with the president now
I'll give you one example now some of
you have heard this before in one of our
monthly meetings with President Bush in
the Roosevelt Room
he was waxing enthusiastically and
eloquently about a new idea that he was
thinking about doing something with and
sitting across the table from him was
David Packard and Packard was looking at
him more and more seriously and when the
president finished David said and I
quote mr. president that is one of the
stupidest damn ideas I've ever heard and
the president said really
and the idea disappeared never heard
from again
and it was really vital that we had
people of the stature and competence and
confidence to say something like that to
the President of the United States
because believe me he rarely hears that
sort of thing otherwise now the typical
time constant of OSTP is something like
15 minutes and under the pressure
responding to issues as they flash
through the transom you frequently find
that you and your colleagues forget the
real reason you're there and the major
goals for the administration and for the
president and so it is vitally important
that on a regular basis in our case it
was one two months we simply got out of
Washington altogether and spent a day
reminding ourselves what those goals
were and what we should be doing about
them
now let me conclude then by noting and I
have obviously a major conflict of
interest but I believe that OSTP can and
should play a vitally important role in
the central administration of this
nation more and more of the decisions of
consequence in this nation involve
substantial Science and Technology
components and it is important not only
to inject the science and technology
where it's needed but also to recognize
where decisions are potentially being
made that can have a huge impact on
science and technology that are not
recognized because those involved in the
decision making simply don't understand
that particular issue I was delighted to
have the opportunity month or so ago to
work with ad David to track down and
kill a rumor that was then current that
the new administration was going to kill
OSTP and ultimately I have to emphasize
we succeeded I believe ultimately the
success of the OSTP director depends
first of all and to a huge degree on the
personal relationship between him or her
and the president there's nothing else
that really matters anywhere near as
much and secondly vitally important is
the relationship with the director of
OMB because we were able to work out a
relationship so that our staffs work
together throughout the year so that
there were no surprises at the end of
the year all the agencies involved got
together in a room like this
and made a joint presentation of their
programs to OMB so that everybody heard
what everybody else was doing in the
case of the presidential initiative
unfortunately we owe in only one
instance were able to make this work in
the Congress where we could bring
congressional committees and
subcommittees together to hear the whole
program simultaneously I think that's a
goal that we need to follow up and work
toward everybody in the Congress and we
had several meetings in the White House
relating to this everyone said that's a
great idea because we had these finely
tuned programs and when they went up to
the Congress they got taken apart and
the pieces were delivered to the dozen
or so committees and subcommittees
that had jurisdiction unfortunately
although everyone agreed that that was a
damn silly way to handle the
congressional oversight whenever we
asked them okay who's going to volunteer
to give up the first piece of turf there
was a deadly silence and then all the
members of the Congress decided they had
other business back on the hill so thank
you ladies and gentlemen and again thank
you to MIT for making this meeting
possible
[Applause]
[Music]
to that first report was a follow-up on
our issuance of a Technology Policy and
Bill Phillips my associate director and
a number of our staff worked very hard
to pull that together it was done with a
high-level largely industrial group of
advisers and it I think played a very
important role in focusing our attention
and the intention of the administration
on a series of technologies some of
which were obvious but some of which
were not and where we were slipping
behind in the international competitive
race areas that could be a real
importance to the nation so that was the
first one the second one was made by a
totally different group and it focused
on our relative status as compared to
activity in other nations it also was
extremely useful out of those
discussions came the idea that what we
really needed was an internal advisory
committee that has been talked about
earlier this morning the RAND
Corporation was the successful bidder
when it went out for bid and well I have
to be very careful what I say about this
in recent years I think that this has
been of considerable use to OSTP but in
its earliest incarnation the RAND
Corporation looked on as a channel
whereby it could really get into the
White House and become a big-time White
House advisory group and so the
relationship between it and OSTP was not
as effective as any of us had hoped
[Applause]
one advantage of coming later in the
morning is that a fair amount of your
subject matter is already covered and
I've been struck this morning with the
commonality of issues faced by a variety
of episodes in the White House through
several presidents
but sometimes repetition has its own
merits so I will I may sound redundant
but I hope that's only meant be able to
underscore the commonality of our
experiences I had the good fortune of
having worked in government up on the
hill in a bipartisan office the OTA for
a number of years before I was asked to
join the administration I had served for
a year and a half in the Nixon years in
in energy matters but this was a
different job and so I was able to come
in to govern into the White House early
in the first days of the new
administration and had the advantage of
being able to help in the identification
of key people for technical positions
all around the government so I had a
unique advantage that was not shared by
most of the other the folks you've
listened to today I would say in in a
sense Enrico what Phil Smith said that
traditionally OSTP and science and to a
degree technology is treated in the
White House political family as somewhat
of a like a bastard at a family reunion
first of all we're seen as a bunch of
nerds in a sea of presidential campaign
errs and professional rough-and-tumble
political types that's the nature of the
White House it has to be that way or it
wouldn't be occupied
but all of these people are daily
immersed in a survival process I'm
reminded of a comment made by the
professor in Shu who's who told the
editor he said I've developed a a some
planning and I've got a long-range plan
in a short-range plan and and the editor
said well what's your short-range plan
professor says to make it through the
day well what's your long-range plan to
put together a series of short-range
plans and that's the practicality of the
nature of the white house of the staff
meetings in the morning of the
interactions between the people it is
strongly focused on driven by political
time constants all of which are very
short compared to most of the time
constants in science and technology I
remember one day trying to describe a
situation with respect to plutonium
management in the world and I had to
give a little essay about plutonium
which the chief of staff asked me to do
and I carefully put together a
three-minute tight presentation of
plutonium in the world economy and why
was such an important thing for the
administration to understand and deal
with and at the end of it there was a
kind of a stunned silence and George
Stephanopoulos said do we have to take
an exam on this and I realized that I
was I was speaking on an important issue
but in the wrong audience at that
particular time this the other feature
of Science in the White House is that it
is competing with embedded White House
power centers that are very zealous of
their authority and of their control of
power it's again the nature of the place
but it's one that that one has to
understand that while you must develop
relationships with these other centers
they will be very zealous of anything
that is perceived to begin to impinge on
their traditional freedoms authorities
in capability
responsibilities and thirdly about the
the OSTP and incidentally I'm going to
try to focus on OSTP as against the
assistant to the president for science
and technology which is a somewhat
different job is that the OSTP is the
result of a congressional act it's
subject to its own separate
appropriations under HUD v and
independent agencies it's not even
listed in the phone book as part of the
executive offices of the president so
there's a in a sense an advantage of
being there by act of Congress but also
that puts you outside the otherwise
tightly knit family within the White
House so the assistant to the president
in the case of Science and Technology is
the only one of all of the assistants to
the president that's also presidential
II nominated Senate confirmed and
therefore responsible to go to the
Congress and testify on a number of
issues it gets a little tricky sometimes
because you have to wear two very
different hats in those two different
commissions the effectiveness as I saw
it and I think as you've heard of it
about it this morning the effectiveness
of OSTP is it is dependent on the
perceived relevance to the president's
priorities and interests and to the
perceived value to the other offices in
the White House to what degree does OSTP
enables these other offices to achieve
their goals in turn this kind of
perception depends very much as Allan
Bromley and others have said on the
personal relationship between that
person and the president the vice
president and other key people in the
White House group that kind of personal
relationship is absolutely vital if you
hope to hope to get things done well in
the case of Clinton and gore both are
intellectual policy wonks gore had his
epiphany up here at Harvard when he took
a course under Roger Revelle and it
resulted in a fairly
clear platform early on in the
administration which I sort of would
describe as first of all economic growth
with a lot obviously a lot of technical
issues involved in get involved in that
process so the economic growth not only
depended on OSTP but also on the
economic Council on the Council of
Economic Advisers on the Domestic Policy
Council all these other parts of the
White House the second platform was
deficit reduction it began early with
the first Clinton budget and it went on
from there with the byline being we're
going to reduce the deficit but we're
gonna do it very carefully and preserve
those things that can help build the
economy and do the rest we're not simply
going to cut government but we're going
to tighten the strings and we're gonna
depend on productivity increases in
order to make our gains more than simply
a budget increases the third area was
health and the concern about a national
health insurance plan and other things
obviously occupied maybe not enough of
the administration's time but it was an
early focused national health being as
important as as education and other
things that underscore our viability
fourth was comprehensive approaches to
environmental issues for instance
tackling not just the salmon issues in
the northwest or endangered species or
lakes or power but the whole of the
northwest region as an environmental
system that needed to be approached
comprehensively the same for the
Mississippi River the hypoxia in the
Gulf and the in the Upper Mississippi
water runoff from from fertilizer the
same for Florida and the and the water
from this the subterranean water flow
down the the southern Florida the sugar
industries all these things combining
together to give a opportunity to
approach holistically fairly major
regions of the country that in turn
called for a lot of coalescing of
capabilities that lay embedded around in
different age agencies of the government
well to work
this we set up our OSTP very similar to
what our predecessors were one of the
big advantages of this legislation was
it creates for Senate for presidential
he nominated Senate confirmed assistant
directors much to the I think to the
envy of many other of the White House
offices and and we divided our world
into four parts science which included
education and agriculture and health
technology which included information
technology and industrial activities
environment which included the full
range of environmental issues and then
finally one in national security and
international affairs very similar
sounding to what you heard in some of
the other incarnations of OSTP
incidentally today we have carrie Ann
Jones here as she still here Carrie Ann
are you here oh there she is over in the
corner who was our assistant director
for national security and international
affairs
we have Duncan Moore who was our a
technology assistant director Ernie
Moniz
where's my work hey you aren't Ernie
here there he is
Ernie I'm glad to see you again Ernie
Moniz who was a key
assistant director for our science and
education work and cliff Gabriel is
currently carrying on that capacity till
until the new administration finds
someone to fill in and Rosina bierbaum
who is also carrying on down there still
in a you know sort of a hold over
capacity til someone comes in to replace
her hopefully soon well to achieve these
various sort of overarching goals
science and technology was seen and
stipulated as being highly relevant if
not essential for the achieving of all
of these goals a cross-cutting enabling
capability rather than a goal in itself
and that was an important distinction it
served the overarching goals rather than
being identified as one and that brought
up and emphasized the notion of
networking and partnerships
as a mechanism for getting our work done
and enabling us to assist in the
networking in the white house meant that
we did and and I think Phil Smith
pointed out the importance of being over
at the mist didn't you mention that feel
importance of being at the mess because
that's where you interact with the other
people with in the way this come complex
very important proximity there's it's
not only real estate its location
location location for the white house as
well
joint appointments was an idea we had
and it worked out to a degree I wish it
had worked out better but we devised a
way to have a senior OSTP person jointly
appointed to for instance the National
Security Council as a I paid the salary
bill but that person in this case
carrion was also appointed as a senior
director in the NSC and that gave a
coupling that was very very helpful we
also tried the same with less success in
other of the White House offices but we
tried to use this mechanism of joint
appointments as much as we could we had
joint policy actions for example in the
first two months of the administration
we issued a paper on the city thing find
the title of it it was essentially
called technology and America's economic
growth that was released by the
president vice president of San Jose in
late winter/early spring of 1993 which
spelled out the case for technology and
its partner science as being the
long-term enabling factor for our
underlying our economic growth we also
issued budget guidance to the agencies
to the executive agencies through a
joint letter published in the spring
signed by both the director of OMB and
myself giving explicit guidance to the
agencies in terms of Science and
Technology priorities so joint policy
actions were an outward and visible sign
of internal attempts to link these
offices together in a produc
so that was one kind of partnership
another partnership was across the
executive branch to do this we built on
the very important earlier work that
Allan Bromley talked about of the fix-it
activities and sort of raced at another
notch in terms of its policy level
within the White House the president
established the National Science and
Technology Council which had the added
features not only was it chaired by the
president and members were the basically
20 the heads of 23 agencies but it also
was able to issue presidential review
directives and presidential decision
directive which enabled then the power
of the President to the force of the
President to be put in coalescing these
agencies together on common issues the
NSTC had a degree of convening
capability was which was very important
and I think all of us would would say
that one important role of OSTP was to
serve the president in bringing together
executive agencies around matters of
mutual concern it's much easier to bring
them over to the White House and have a
sit-down knock-down drag-out session
than to have them meet somewhere some
neutral place in town or in one of the
agencies there's it's a magical
capability that is is important to use
we used the the NSTC as a means of
developing a number of initiatives for
instance simple things like the Defense
Department of Defense had a whole
weather satellite system and so too did
NOAA and after more than little cajoling
and and more than a little time we were
able to get those systems converged into
a single weather satellite system for
the nation I also remind you that
sometime later one distinguished member
of Congress declared one day that he was
going to get rid of NOAA and there's
weather satellites because why do you
need all these government weather
satellites up there when you got the the
the weather station on television he he
learned better later on we also resolved
and and had a presidential initiative on
declassifying the global positioning
satellite system in order to enable it
to move into the commercial markets as
well as serve in a dual capacity for
national security this was a very
important development and it took a
coalescing of Defense State Commerce CIA
and I'm not sure who all else but you
can see the kind of White House
convening that had to take place to
enable this to move forward we developed
over in this in this case it took two
full years to develop an initiative on
biomass research and utilization because
we had to coalesce would you believe it
the Department of Agriculture in the
Department of Energy
into a single working group and I have
two minutes Azzurri and time is an
essential element in bringing people
together but we were pleased we were
able to do that we resolved a bunch of
conflicts conflicts between agencies on
on on policy decisions and on
declarations of regulations dioxin MTBE
mercury LED particulate matter in the
air all of these took a convening at the
White House of different agencies that
were stakeholders in these issues to
resolve the differences between the
agencies before they came to to announce
the results we have to approve the
launch of the Cassini space probe to
Saturn because it contained a lot of
plutonium-238 and it was going to go
swinging around Venus and back around
the Earth twice and on out to the other
system and there are a lot of people
personally lobbying the President on
this and it turned out that was my job
to to make the decision on that launch
or to refer it to the president and in
this case it was very clear to me that I
needed to make that decision
not try to leave that one on the
president so there are some of these
funny little side issues that pop up so
that the executive branch integration is
one thing let me mention two others
briefly government and private sector
bringing understanding mutual
self-interest on the part of the public
and an apart on the private sector to
achieve goals that have mutual benefits
for both those sectors one of the one of
the largest was the partnership for a
new generation of vehicles and very good
where are you Mary Mary is a hero
because she was at commerce and I I was
pleased to help recruit her to commerce
Mary took on this task at commerce and
included six federal agencies all three
of the big three motors and others into
a single well coordinated activity that
still is extent and making good progress
I won't mention the others but it's this
notion that if you can be like the
old-time barn raising cooperation
between people where the whole can be
greater than the sum of the parts then
things can work better than by command
and control international partnerships
the shaping of the Space Station
inherited from the Cold War and
transformed to an international venture
the largest peacetime international
technology venture in history was an
early activity of the administration and
Chuck vest are you here Chuck bless his
heart he agreed to chair this meeting
and I'll never forget we have to do it
quickly and Chuck conceived of bringing
the Russians in and doing all sorts of
things and and at the end writing this
report up Chuck Smith the entire night
and saw the next morning while he was
helping write this report I think was
the first time he had done that since he
had been a graduate student but you were
a hero Chuck changing the high-energy
physics situation from the disaster of
the SS C the superconducting
supercollider
into a time in which we realized we
needed to join the international effort
in particle physics and become much more
a an active partner over
CERN the global climate change issue we
carried on from where Alan had taken it
and we believe it is still moving
forward the a lot of bilateral work
particularly on on the weapons control
and nuclear weapons components and
plutonium control with Russia but other
similar things with other countries in
this case I worked very closely with the
vice president and then finally the the
Committees of the OSTP were very
important the PCAST as Alan pointed out
can play a key role if it has direct
access to the president we did this with
respect to energy research and
development to international energy
issues to bio complexity to plutonium
control and nuclear weapons where it
only only 10 days went by between the
time we briefed the President on that
issue and when he met with Yeltsin and
came to an agreement on plutonium
disposition the creation of the National
bio ethics Advisory Committee or
commissioned by the president which
which was chaired by Harold Shapiro
another one of our heroes that we it
took us a long time to put it in place
because Congress had failed to be able
to create it in earlier years and it
tackled very effectively the issues of
the use of human subjects in advanced
biomedicine and has has its I would say
its agenda cut out for it for about
probably the next 50 years so ultimately
then partnerships were a key word but
they began in the White House and they
ended up in our international work we
were trying to link our citizen
governors two sources of specialized
knowledge in effective ways and I won't
try to judge the outcome I'm reminded of
a person who asked Mao Zedong once what
he thought of the 18th century French
Revolution and he thought for a minute
and he said it's a little too early to
tell thank you
I guess is going to Nealon okay all
right the Avenue the the word and the
role of votes OTA and the role of as a
science advisor to the president the
impact of both just and why did OTA go
out ta was a pleasant job because we
never tried to tell Congress what they
ought to do we tried to give him a good
description of their options and we were
governed by a bipartisan bicameral Board
so I didn't have to really give advice
so much as information that was
condensed and and policy relevant when I
got the White House I lost a lot of
friends because I had to start giving
advice it's like that that essay the
young man won in the 8th grade he won
the essay contest
but one of the world's great men and he
said my assay is about Socrates Socrates
was a great man he gave advice to other
people he was poisoned
thank you very much Duncan and Jack it's
always a mistake to follow J Gibbons
Here I am again
it's a terrific pleasure to be at MIT
MIT --zz connections with science
technology and so many other things
they're so important in the nation this
is quite extraordinary but it gives me a
chance to mention explicitly the many
advisers that I had the great pleasure
to work with on PCAST certainly Chuck
vast but also Mario Molina John Deutsch
Phil sharp and Ernie Moniz of course you
know worked with us in the White House
and and before he moved over to energy
and was very important to that
department and our ability to do some
good things during some really difficult
times with the Department of Energy I
should also say John Holdren served on
key PCAST and he's from that sister
institution up the road was very
effective I also apologize for my voice
and in any incoherence that you made yet
mr. Porter had mentioned allergies
earlier and I think a lot of us have
gotten serious allergy attacks we need
to put my money into allergy research
it's a great honor for me to be here so
many distinguished predecessors quite an
extraordinary occasion many if not all
of you I've called it called on in my in
my years in Washington for good advice
especially indebted to Jack Gibbons
because he was my predecessor in the
White House and he had an important role
in bringing me to Washington to the NSF
job and bring me over to the White House
and I'm grateful for that he gave me
lots of good advice as did bill golden
Bill Goldman when I asked about how you
work in the White House he said well
Neal you remember when you were a little
boy he always says that remember when
you're a little boy you did this
experiment with a microscope and the
slide and the Paramecium and the India
ink and the Paramecium would come up and
then back off and then go over here and
then back off and then finally would
make it wherever he or she I don't know
about Piranesi we're going and I
followed that advice I remembered that
about
I saw the time and I got some ink in my
nose from time to time but by and large
it is a pretty good advice and it's
consistent I think with all else that
we've heard about how you work in the
White House a jack had a difficult test
is selecting from a long list and I will
be have the same problem and I'm only
going to mention a few areas I'll talk a
little bit about the budget the
president clinton's last budget a little
bit about the government university
partnership that we worked on about
space policy if there's time cloning
missile defense and if anybody asks a
question I'll talk about the Clinton
Blair statement on the human genome
project that had an impact a negative
one on the biotechnology market that's
one of those surprises it's one of those
things you would like to have done a
little better but it was an important
statement nonetheless first of all the
budget as Jack has said President
Clinton and Vice President Gore
certainly understand understood all
along the importance of Science and
Technology and we're champions of it I
didn't have the opportunity to work as
closely with Vice President Gore because
he was busy off doing other things on
the other hand that allowed the
president I think to spend more time
thinking about Science and Technology
which he had generally wanted the vice
president to work closely on and of
course the vice president loved science
and technology so that worked really
well but the president's last budget was
unprecedented in many ways it enabled us
to get some focus on the balance issue
by identifying the 21st century research
fund which is essentially all the
fundamental half of the overall federal
R&D budget so that we could make the
point that while you're increased that's
already been made here very eloquently
by congressman Porter that while you are
growing the NIH budget roughly tracking
GDP over time which makes sense to me
seems like the right trajectory for me
you also need to build up the chemistry
in the physics and the math computer
science the engineering fields so
important and you do that through
funding the National Science Foundation
the science programs and Department of
Energy defense NASA and the other
agencies so we worked hard on that and
this budget gave us a chance to bring
forward fairly significant
in all of those important research
programs in Congress was quite receptive
to that and I think it's very impressive
gave bipartisan support generally to
this budget and we did very well the
reason the Congress supported the
president is because many members of
Congress understand how important
Science and Technology are even if
they're not on the radar screen every
day even if they aren't the things that
members get elected or get sent home
about still it's very important and many
members of Congress all members of
Congress I think want to do good things
for the country so there is that
bipartisan spirit but also a lot of
people worked very hard to put this
budget together many in the White House
many in Washington many out here so
we've got people in the audience that
worked enormously hard to get the
attention of members of Congress to
explain this issue of balance and the
importance of the increased investment
in science technology and we're very
grateful for that kind of effort within
that budget there were a few important
initiatives that that I would highlight
certainly a continuation of the new
technical new technology R&D investments
to find better ways more efficient and
cleaner ways of producing energy those
programs started during my predecessors
time also the information technology
initiative that had been started by the
president a couple of years earlier upon
the recommendation of his Advisory
Committee on information technology PTAC
to increase the investment in long-term
fundamental research in computer science
and communication and we continued that
initiative and then a brand-new
initiative in this FY 0-1 budget was
that in nanotechnology and Chuck vest
really helped us on PCAST by chairing
the panel PCAST panel that looked at the
program we were putting together
involving many agencies on increasing
the investment in nanoscale science and
engineering and then recommending to the
president what to do and PCAST role here
was extremely important the president
was delighted with the nanotechnology
initiative I'd had the chance to brief
him on it on more than one occasion and
I remember in a budget meeting nobody
else in the White House or very few
other people in the White House were
we're familiar with nanotech no
remember a budget meeting in the
Roosevelt Room we were going through the
list of initiative Sheila's page after
page of things people want to do more
police on the streets more teachers in
the classrooms very very important
initiatives but there's a certain
competition there so when we got to
nanotechnology a lot of people tabled
into what it was and they turned to me
thinking this has to be Neal's fault
he's the only nerd at the table so he's
gotta know something about this and I
said mr. president I think you know what
this initiative is all about and the
president said let's see nanotechnology
is this tiny little initiative a lot of
people table did not get the joke but I
said I said that's right mr. president
but will require some substantial money
and so I did many agencies play
important roles National Science
Foundation NASA do e NIH it's a highly
multidisciplinary and extremely
important initiative I'd be excited to
talk several hours about it but I will
not at this point but it did go in the
budget for a 60% increase in the federal
investment in nanoscale science and
engineering when you put all this
package together president requested
more but 60 56 percent is not bad so it
I'm hopeful that the initiative will get
positive consideration by the Congress
this next time around another area I
should say something we didn't do so
well on another really important area is
critical infrastructure protection Rd I
think had David come in and on on this
it includes cyber t it includes cyber
issues but it includes the whole
infrastructure and banking I mean the
health sector everything that's
increasingly dependent on information
infrastructure so PCAST john deutsch was
instrumental here PCAST had a look at
this and said what we really need is a
non-government organization they can
stay abreast of fast changing
technologies work closely with industry
very closely with industry and and
identify those areas that need
researched and figure out how to get the
information out to to the private sector
we put together what I thought was a
terrific proposal but for various
reasons that Congress did not smile on
at this time around it's an issue that's
not going to go away
and I'm very hopeful that Congress will
do something about it in this session
the University Government Partnership is
extremely important for all the reasons
that we all know Chuck vest and some of
his PCAST colleagues drew our attention
to the fact that some of these stresses
that have been talked about over the
years including Academy reports have to
do with awkwardness in in in working
with the accordionist on the part of the
universities and working with the
federal government to support R&D we
have some rules that are not so easy to
follow even as some rules that are
frankly dumb and so couldn't we have a
look at those and try to straighten the
situation out and so we did we worked
closely with OMB on the matter and we
ended up with first of all a set of
principles that that we hope in future
will guide this partnership and at least
by looking at those principles you'll
know when you're getting ready to do
something dumb or not then in the case
of specifics a21 had some of these
problems in it and we were able to
identify those and OMB indicated changes
that should be made and in those changes
are be may are being made such issues as
how you handle voluntary uncommitted
cost-sharing which was sort of one of
the dumb things that came out of the
past the work force has been mentioned
and I think the imperative of doing
something about the future science
technology workforce which I think we'll
hear from read about is I mean that in
my view is the biggest challenge of all
the different challenges that I talk
about when I talk about barriers to
progress in science and technology or
challenges we need to deal with this
workforce challenge is something that we
really don't I think we don't know how
to get hold of and the numbers are scary
the demographic shifts are fairly rapid
and we simply don't know what to do so
we've got to get at it I think one way
to think about it is is that young
people I mean boys and girls all over
the country in virtually every community
represent some of the brightest talent
potentially brightest talent available
it's there we just have to get to it
also young people are very curious early
on that's why we really like sign
until we get to school and then we
suddenly don't like science anymore
because the idea of inquiry somehow got
lost in the classroom well it's not lost
to agency like NSF and and too many
quite exciting efforts in education
underway also enquiries what research is
all about its what excited us and got so
many of us into research careers so you
know it doesn't make sense that's really
the way to learn science and shouldn't
we be able to expose more young people
to science I think yeah I at least
believe that that is the case the the
other thing I would say is that some
young people are turned on just by the
excitement of intellectual discovery
just a thought they're curious they they
they want to learn more and and yeah
they're little nerdy sometimes other
young people are excited about the
thought that they would change the world
they want something to happen to solve
some of these major problems of the
world and they'd like to like to have a
career that does that and they look at
science and engineering and they say
what's the point because they don't
understand that science engineering and
technology changes the world we've got
to help them understand what's the point
nobody else can do that but the Science
and Technology community I'm sorry that
was a little bit of a preaching but I
believe it deeply and we'll continue to
talk about the concept of the citizen
scientists I think it is extremely
important for us to think about as a new
year area of our responsibility I was
skipped space policy except to say it
was a big issue we're proud that we were
able to get the space station up off the
drawing board and actually up there and
it's working
continuously occupied I'd like to go up
but I don't have twenty million dollars
okay that my wife will let me spend you
know for that for that particular
endeavor it also is an example of a
wonderful partnership that was difficult
has been difficult with Russia because
Russia has gone through such such hard
transitional problems in the economy and
in just in society in general but it
worked it was very important to include
the Russians as a partner they brought
technology and knowledge to the table
they brought mirror which gave us
experience for our astronauts we never
would have had otherwise so with all of
its wrinkles and warts it was a very
important partnership and we're very
happy about it we've had some failures
with our Mars program the faster better
cheaper didn't work as well as we hoped
with the Mars investments but those
failures still pale by comparison with
the giant failure in 1993 of essentially
the whole Mars program and this is a
better way as dan Golan himself has said
we need to do it better
and we agree and we were the White House
oversight of the the investigation of
what went wrong with the Mars failures
in the new plan to go forward OST was
very involved in the political arena
when Dolly was announced the was clear
since we have no law on cloning of
anybody people or animals that something
needed to be done
president turned to to Harold Shapiro
and and back the National bio ethics
Advisory Committee for advice they
provided advice very quickly in the
president edition issued an executive
order that banned the cloning of the
human being as you know that's the I
think the only thing on the table right
now in the way of law but Congress was
looking at a number of steps then right
on the heels of that came the stem-cell
breakthroughs in bring ussen the the
research on embryonic stem cells that
showed that you really could couldn't
multiply these cells and develop whole
lines and so again we turn to end back
for its advice and the president
ultimately determined that it was okay
for NIH based on its legal opinion to go
forward to support research on existing
embryonic stem cell lines but not to
derive stem cells from embryos again
there are people on the hill thinking
about clamping down on that preventing
NIH from do that research I think that's
not a good idea
I believe the scientific issues coupled
with the enormous promise that this has
for human health
and finally the ethical considerations
and n-back gave this suggest that this
really ought to go forward well there's
lots more I could say we were involved
in national missile defense we were
quiet
outside but we were not quiet inside I
know that our voice was heard on that
matter as the president made his
decisions genetically modified organisms
were very much around and in my time
because of what went on in in UK in
particular and then throughout Europe
people all over the world are scared
about genetically modified organisms but
less so in this country and I think
that's because of the confidence that
they have in our ability to protect our
food for our people and our environment
but this issue has not gone away not
going to go away there'll be much more
to do here and there'll be many more
issues that challenge our public's
values attitudes experiences there'll be
many more way places in which science
and technology is going to come into
potential conflict with what people care
deeply about and the technology is
moving awfully fast so a body like the
national bio ethics Advisory Committee
is very important and consideration of
more research activities and more
sensitivity to ethical issues in science
and technology also I think must be the
must be an important criterion in the
future for how we go about putting our
programs together one one more thing
I'll just say all I really did was to
come in after Jack Jack put together an
extraordinary Office of Science
Technology Policy build a high level of
credibility hired terrific people like
carrie ann and duncan and jeff smith who
was our exec who was really our it's
hard to describe what jeff does and keep
him out of jail he's the guy who
understands how the west wing warrants
he understands what campaign people do
he knows what he knows how Congress
works and and i just can't say enough
good about his contributions but he's
representative of the quality that jack
put together in OSTP my job is to come
in and try not to mess it up and with a
few exceptions I think I succeeded thank
you very much
[Applause]
I think it is a problem Oh STP first of
all is not now is not small it has about
60 people if you include people on loan
from agencies like NSF and NASA and so
on so from the perspective of some of
these other councils it looks like a
pretty big office and so that's just
sort of an internal problem of how do
you go about getting the budget up but
of course the rand activity should be
funded through STP in my view it's very
hard I saw it from NSF's point of view
so I said over at NSF and I thought
what's going on I mean what how do I
evaluate this given NSS responsibilities
so it doesn't make any sense it ought to
be funded by OSTP the other thing is
that there's very little funding for PKS
activities a lot of what PKS did that's
why they're such champions well there's
a lot of reasons they're champions but
but they they did many of these things
on their own hook institutional support
company support maybe even xeroxing out
of their own pockets we shouldn't we
shouldn't be having to do that and so
resources are very limited last thing I
would say is expectations are just going
up science and technology is so much a
part of everything else going on and the
national agenda that to expect that
that's just going to be done better and
better and better being stretched as
thinly as we are is is I think a
mistaken impression so I believe the
resources our problem
you